for months it was one of the few places
in the world
untouched by the pandemic well everyone
in nineveh
is a little uh scared and weary about uh
koved right now because uh we've kept it
out for
out of the nouveau for eight months but
now it's here it's a territory the size
of western europe
sparsely populated with just 25
communities
only accessible by plane but despite its
remoteness
nunuvut hasn't been spared by the
coronavirus
the majority of cases are in the hamlet
of arviat
a community of just under three thousand
people most of nunavut citizens are
indigenous
inuit they've faced a legacy of canada's
colonial policies
and are already vulnerable jobs are
scarce
and a housing shortage means homes are
overcrowded
something that's especially dangerous
during a pandemic
and a lockdown nothing good comes out of
overcrowded house you have mental health
issues you have health issues
you may have family violence issues
there are only two
hospitals in the territory and residents
are regularly flown to
southern canada for medical treatment no
one's been flown out because of covid19
yet but the health system is nearly at
its limit
that's the rationale for bringing these
orders in place
because everything that nunavut do to
reduce their contacts to reduce the size
of their social bubble
that helps us that helps reduce the
impact of covid19 gatherings are
restricted
schools and non-essential businesses are
closed
there's extra focus on students mental
health
it's a young population which for years
has struggled with high rates of suicide
and depression
they've been given take-home learning
packages and teachers and support
workers
are regularly checking in are caring for
each other they're going to make sure if
someone is
is uh sick or is alone in the house that
they're going to make sure that they're
taken care of they're going to make sure
that they have enough food
we're a very caring society and we will
be taking care of each other
and looking out for each other it's
believed many of the cases are linked to
isolation hubs in southern canada where
infections are surging
premier savikata says the territory's
isolation is one of its strongest assets
right now
we are going to stop the spread of this
virus and we are going to prevail it may
take a little while but we will
this is a region that's used to being
snowed in and
cut off covid19 may have gotten in
but the nunavut are confident it won't
stay for long
alexandra byers al jazeera